Auckland International Airport
processes 21 million passengers
every year and climbing.
Customs and Immigration
have just been alerted to a visiting
Lithuanian woman with quite a history.
Officer James is keen to take on the case.
It looks like she had some trouble
in the US on en route to New Zealand.
She's coming out of UK
so I'm going to have a talk with her
and see what interactions she had
with the US authorities
en route to New Zealand.
I need to ask you your reasons
for coming to New Zealand
as well as what happened over in the USA.
The woman tries to front foot
her situation by producing correspondence
with New Zealand authorities
to avoid delay.
You see that you needed
to have a visa for New Zealand
and you have a very important
family events here in New Zealand.
Indeed, actually,
I'm visiting my boyfriend
who actually who lives
in New Zealand. Oh, great.
But I just
want to make sure that I can call you
from an immigration perspective.
Lithuanian nationals can travel
to New Zealand as visitors without a visa.
But James wants to know
that she's not here to disappear.
Can I.
Can I ask
how long you were living in the USA?
For like 17, 18 years.
Seventeen years?
Eighteen years?
And what Visa did you hold?
What Visa were you holding?
Um, I was, the Visa um,
I was issued the Visa over 20 years ago
I don’t exactly remember
a truly specific Visa that was issued.
James knows she's lying.
His American counterparts have
already told him she's never had a U.S.
visa. What about USA?
What about USA?
Yeah, what happened in the USA?
At Auckland’s Air Cargo facility,
Customs officer Hayden believes
this parcel is worth checking out.
So we've identified a consignment here
that we believe is suspicious.
It's come from
West Africa, the country of Mali.
It's been declared as motor parts
worth 300,000 NZD, which is quite high
considering the site of the consignment.
There doesn't seem to be any padding
or protection for it.
It's hard to imagine what car parts
could be worth $300,000,
let alone why the exporters
were keen to get them here so quickly.
They agreed to pay 60 grand in customs
charges for the privilege.
The items that are inside
are very poorly packaged.
You'd expect there
to be some packaging material
or some sort of order to the way
that they package, but it just doesn't.
It looks like they've
just been thrown in there together
and for something worth so much.
Yeah, the alarm bells are definitely
ringing here.
There’s some organic material here
of some kind, um, that doesn’t fit
the description of motor vehicle parts,
we just wouldn’t expect
to find organic material in there.
The Republic of Mali seems to feature
highly optimistic car park dealers.
The parts are worth a fraction
of even the shipping cost.
This is the sort of product
you could pick up at your local parts
store in New Zealand for
a small amount of money.
It's just not consistent
with the valuation.
I'm not a mechanic,
but I would expect this area
here to be free moving.
It looks like a bearing of some kind,
but it's rock solid.
So again, alarm
bells are definitely ringing here.
Hayden's no mechanic,
but he knows how to swing a hammer.
That's broken the metal straight off.
So, again,not not
something you'd expect from a part
so expensive.
While Hayden had his bearings
right, the manufacturers didn’t.
Hello, what do we have here?